ready
[Music]
hello Danny
hey youtubers is Charlie so the Punisher
is getting ready to film new Netflix
stuff there are only two options
defenders and iron fist so I'm gonna
explain the shooting schedule and what's
going on because New York Comic Con is
coming up Jeff lobe the president of
Marvel television was talking about all
the Marvel stuff that he's bringing to
New York Comic Con they do a bunch of
presentations of course they'll be doing
Netflix DUP they'll be hyping that up
because Luke Cage is dropping just as
New York Comic Con is getting started so
they want to promote that they also want
to show off some new Iron Fist footage
so they're gonna be talking about all
kinds of Marvel Netflix stuff but like
back during the summer during San Diego
comic-con Jon Bernthal kind of poked his
head in at the beginning of the Luke
Cage panel just to say hey everybody
really happy to be here much love from
the Punisher he had like this crazy
beard on and then kind of took off just
like you know thank you so much for all
the love you guys would be giving the
Punisher so since then they have kind of
locked down the Punisher Season 1
they're developing scripts they have a
showrunner
they've already cast their first villain
they're gonna start shooting pretty suit
probably early next year but here we are
heading into the first week of October
in Jeph Loeb said that Jon Bernthal is
only going to be able to be at New York
Comic Con for one day on Saturday
because of his Netflix filming schedule
and like I said they have not even
gotten close to start filming the
punisher series yet the only series
they're filming right now is kind of
like closing down iron fist they're
probably doing some touch-ups on that
they're mostly done filming that series
in starting to film Marvel's defenders
so it's been a little while but the
actor who plays daredevil had just
confirmed that they would start filming
defenders towards the end of this year
cut to now saying Jon Bernthal is
filming Netflix stuff so he can't be at
every single day of New York Comic Con
following the breadcrumb trail back to
the set so hell yeah filming defenders
and I know a lot of people are wondering
well you know if Punisher were to cross
over into iron fist what would be
happening because they haven't had a lot
of crossovers in the comics the one
really big one that they had was shadow
land so what I think is happening is
this Punisher is just popping up in
every one series in a really small way
like cameo level
he'll be much bigger in defenders so as
for what he's actually doing during Iron
Fist during those scenes we'll want
it'll probably be to help out Iron Fist
at some point whether or not they know
each other or they meet he might just be
in the neighborhood on unrelated
Punisher business stuff that will build
context for what's going on in Punisher
season 1 but maybe he'll help him out
with the Harold Meacham problem who's
actually being played by this actor
David Wenham you might remember him from
Lord of the Rings or some other series
he's played a lot of comedic roles too
so it's gonna be weird to see him play
this big Netflix villain he was Danny
rands father's partner they formed a
firm together Rand Meechum that's why
Danny Rand is so rich he's kind of like
the Batman of the defenders he has all
this money so he funds the team the part
of the conflict is that Harald Meechum
you know very powerful businessmen very
wealthy was involved in the death of
Danny's father so there's a bit of a
revenge arc happening during Iron Fist
but you can imagine someone like Harold
Meacham with a lot of money probably
going to have loose ties or dealings
with the hand in the same way that the
king Pitt did during daredevil now like
the kingpin is not part of the hand but
he did interact with them like he did
enter into business contracts with them
so even though iron fist kind of exists
is his own self-contained story like
it's an origin story for him I'm
expecting the other Netflix stories to
bleed into it a little bit so you see a
little bit of kingpin a little bit of
hand stuff stuff that will lead into
defenders because iron fist is the last
series before defenders so the end of
that will lead directly into the first
episode of defenders so naturally there
has to be a lot of crossover stuff
happening so that's probably why we're
hearing about Punisher filming stuff but
just to be clear they're not gonna start
filming the actual Punisher series till
early next year so any stories that you
hear about Punisher filming Netflix
stuff for the rest of this year through
the rest of 2016 it's all gonna be for
the other series but just remember even
though he's technically not the villain
anymore it's not like daredevil versus
Punisher anymore or Punisher versus the
defenders or anything like that
that doesn't mean that they have
achieved their sh warm amoment the idea
is is that that will happen at the end
of defenders let me know in the comments
what do you guys think the Punishers
do when he runs into the other defenders
do you think that he's gonna treat them
the same way he treated daredevil he's
definitely capable of respect he has a
certain level of affection for his dog
so we know that like he is capable of
liking other people but it's not really
in his nature to be touchy-feely or even
open with his feelings so his way of
showing you that he likes you is by not
shooting you in the face but it's gonna
be a lot of fun I cannot wait to see the
Punisher meet Luke Cage it'll just be a
lot of nodding and mutual respect
grunting and flexing of muscles Punisher
buying tickets to the gun show but just
a reminder it's gonna be wheels up for
Episode one of Luke Cage or really all
the episodes next Friday or actually
Thursday at midnight if you stay up
really late like if you have the day off
from work or you don't have school on
Friday it is gonna be awesome
I'm probably gonna post my episode 1
video later that morning and then the
rest of the videos will just post like
one every couple days until I get to the
rest of it'll probably take me about two
weeks to get through all Luke Cage
videos I mean I binge watch it in like
two days but it really takes me a little
bit longer to get through all the videos
just because it takes time to make but
we have Ghost Rider Doctor Strange is
gonna be dropping really soon there's
supposed to be some spider-man footage
in the next couple weeks that's
unconfirmed though but whatever ends up
happening I'll totally do a video for it
so be sure to subscribe to get
everything they'll probably at least one
more Luke Cage trailer in next week to
what you guys wait for that to post you
can click here for my punisher season 1
teaser trailer and you can click here
for my Iron Fist trailer thank you so
much for watching everybody let's high
five I'll see you guys tonight